weil berg 13
dessen drei werke
papa mama kind
die drei zinnen in den dolomiten sind
weltberühmte berge und wenn man dort
urlaub macht dann hat man die absicht
die einsamkeit der natur zu genießen
das gilt auch für die kleine familie von
der anzahl in den vielen 13 erzählt
vater mutter kind wie es der kleine
junge einmal auf die formel bringt
gewissermaßen und diesen drei personen
entsprechen diese drei majestätischen
berge die den äußeren rahmen für diese
geschichte bildet
ich will noch mal ins tiefe
die beobachtungen dessen dass in dieser
familie vor sich gehen sind sehr subtil
denn wenn ein kind zwischen zwei
erwachsenen steht die einander lieben
aber die von frühere partner hatten die
also eine geschichte haben dann ist das
eine ganze reihe von sehr fein
wahrnehmbaren spannungen und das video
die anzahl sehr schön
lässt uns daran teilhaben wie diese drei
menschen die sich dann zurückgezogen
haben einander auch ständig beobachten
wie sie es ja genau darauf achten was
der andere gerade tut oder wissen lassen
möchte und so weiter
und mitte
links
vier jahren zu weil es ist der zweite
größere film und man sieht hier ganz
schön wie er eben mit der natur arbeitet
wie er mit den darstellern gearbeitet
ich denke man kann 13 jahren auf jeden
fall empfehlen also einen speziellen
film für diese saison alle die
vielleicht nicht den star wars gehen
wollen oder schon zweimal dort waren
können mit diesem film auf jeden fall
versuchen